- If you're dating someone,
interviewing a new friend,
interviewing a new
co-worker, this is a test
that helps you figure out sort
of who someone is on
a subconscious level--
- Okay.
- So the first thing I'm gonna do is--
- Oh, I am nervous.
- And you should be.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna ask you your
favorite animal, don't say Henry.
(laughs)
Don't say your dog, cause
that's what I wanna do
I wanna say my dog--
- I wasn't gonna say my dog.
- I want to say my dog,
I want to say my horse,
your favorite animal--
- The wolf.
- One that you admire, wolf
that's a great one and
three characteristics
about a wolf,
like why you like them.
- I like them cause they're strong,
- Yup.
I like them cause they're fast,
And I like them cause
they travel in packs,
I like a buddy system (laughs)
- I love, okay
that's genius.
- Yeah.
- The second thing is
your favorite article
of clothing and it doesn't have
to be something you're wearing,
I was like oh like a ball
gown, is it a pair of socks
I end up doing a hoodie
cause they're like classic--
- Yeah
- They're warm, they're sort
of gender neutral, I like that,
like what would be your
favorite article of clothing?
- [Kelly] Jeans
- [Whitney] Jeans, right?
- Yeah.
- [Whitney] They are--
- Well mine are stretchy.
(everybody laughs)
Mine are very stretchy.
- Do you have those pregnancy lady--
- You know what?
I wore them when I was pregnant
and I thought about it afterwards,
but then I was like this is too much,
you should stop eating and work out.
- The ones with the tire around the top.
- It's all elastic in the
front, no I like regular jeans.
I'm a regular jeans girl,
but I like them because they are,
they're like second skin.
So I like that--
- Yeah, they're classic maybe.
- I'm a mom and I'm
running around all the time
and then we have a ranch in Montana
so you really don't wear
ball gowns in Montana.
That's a little weird.
- And then your favorite body of water,
it can be a swimming
pool, a river, a lake.
I picked the new river in West Virginia--
- A river.
- Because I use to spend
time there as a kid--
- I would say river as, well
I named my daughter River,
so I better like it.
- Oh!
And three characteristics of a river,
I picked that too so it was like--
- Oh, I like that they connect all bodies
of water, I've heard--
- [Whitney] Yeah, they're
connected--
- Yeah.
- [Whitney] Sometimes they're like rough,
sometimes they're not--
- Yes, but I like
[Kelly] a rushing river,
I like to hear the sound
of it, it's calming.
- Okay, so and I'm gonna tell you what all
of this means.
So--
- Okay I am ready--
- (laughs) Your fave--
- How screwed up am I?
- [Whitney] It's not that bad--
- Okay.
- [Whitney] Believe it or not--
- It is.
- Yeah your favorite animal is
how you see yourself.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- Wolf. What was it?
- Strong, fast, and I
travel in packs. Yes!
(audience applauds)
I do!
- And your favorite
article of clothing reveals
how other people perceive you.
Jeans--
- Oh yes, very comfortable--
- [Whitney] Stretchy--
- With herself, maybe far too comfortable
with herself--
- And then your favorite body of water is
how you view sex.
- Yeah, you know what it works.
I like the sound of it--
- Connects.
- I like it rushing and--
- What was it connects
all things--
- And it connects all things.
I love rivers.